hello and welcome to another wonderful
lobby GDC session live from the gamespot
studios mere blocks away from moscone
center where GDC was happening probably
winding down a little but now a lot of
hungover people Matt Lee's yeah I'm one
of the many hungover people and yeah I'm
just sort of increasingly turning into
Batman as a week but it's been a good
show well don't worry you don't have to
talk all the time it's not Lee's people
keep telling me that yeah because I
because we have a wonderful other guests
we have four people sitting around the
desk here have very happy to be joined
by mr. cliff Adams at shreve Jackson
from spawn on me podcast podcast I sort
of got wise to back in January and I've
been listening to every single week
since a gentleman great to finally meet
you same here man so happy to have us
here this is nuts this is no right yes
yeah this is a very awesome studio and
let's talk some games yeah let's talk
about it I first of all want to talk
about what you guys been doing since you
got here I know you were hosting the mix
over my chin I just down the road boy
them how was that what's like yeah that
was so real yeah I had never been in
their studios I've never done anything
that big yet it was like walking around
and like oh okay there's people who are
gonna watch me on live t kind of
something Stevie doesn't apply and it
was that basically that's exactly what I
said like 90 minutes to receive that
sentence over on TV a Des Moines materia
thing hey mom I mean I face a little bit
yeah kinda cuz it's weird cuz it's like
your twitch stream stuff is like you
know you expect a couple people to kind
of watch it and that's it but you're in
your house Rio you guys no lights in
like real cameras and I stay put behind
the cameras yeah there's no one like
giving you stuff to tell you things like
make sure you say that thing I'm like
okay I got it fun experience knows
awesome oh so awesome i got to hang out
was like garnet Lee who's there who have
been a fan of forever yeah yeah and like
all that stuff game all those people who
really dope it was really fun and so for
folks who don't know you guys tell us a
little bit of it a little bit of a spot
on me how long you guys been doing it
watch your focus how's it how long is it
how habits been progressing since you
guys started sure so we've been wanting
me for just over two years we just
recorded our 100 first episode which is
pretty awesome gratulations all about
the division yep yeah all the way in
about the division and yeah you know we
we have you know great gaming
conversations with like a focus you know
on a diversity in the industry so we
bring on designers and publishers and
like Game Journalists you know and we
just really you know try to add
something different than like the
typical like you know check the boxes
for graphics and score yeah and like all
that stuff and we've had shows that like
you know that I focus on like specific
games like the division and as well as
like shows that like my kit and into
issues of a representation of gender &
games and things like that so you know
it's been a really great time and we've
you know obviously love coming to events
like at GDC because we get to see a lot
of the people that we interact with on
like Twitter and like this book and like
all that stuff in the flesh yeah it's
funny when I started listening to
podcasts I had to I was like googling
where pro cargo is it's like I've never
heard of that city it's like a state of
mind right it's like I was like I said
somewhere between Chicago and Brooklyn
is it like it's it's like area 51 right
not on any recorded Maps there yeah it's
great like you guys talk about obviously
diversity in terms of racial diversity
in terms of like gender & with inka
video game stuff what I like about the
podcast as well as that is that it's
diverse in terms of the subject matter
you kind of never know you're gonna get
like the next week one week it's like
talking about the division next week
it's like throwing shade but like david
jaffe about like crazy like you guys
seem to put a lot of effort into making
sure that every show is original in sort
of a unique way yeah we kind of want to
talk to people most people we have on
the show everybody we have on the show
we you specifically really like what
they do anyway but we think that most
people don't kind of get that 360
version of those people they kind of get
this very kind of narrow version of them
and it was something we had Jeff you and
I was like I want to just talk to Jackie
about you know the game but also he has
a lot of things that are in his brain
yeah I want to know what he thinks about
politics I want to think about you know
all the things he thinks about all these
other subjects and then a racial issue
came up in that discussion yeah yeah and
it was great because we didn't expect
that no so they just randomly came up
and it was amazing because he had like
really thoughtful things to say it was
it was actually really nice to hear him
have those conversations cuz people
think of him as a thoughtful person yeah
think of him as just a flamethrower all
yeah ranting and throwing it at ya and I
was like he's a human yes thoughts that
are nuanced but you know let's talk
about those guys are good at disarming
people it's a good trait to have you
watched his nuance is good you know you
know I can't find it on the internet but
it's good it's there's like what's the
impetus behind that them because
obviously you must look at like
mainstream games media then be like okay
this is like either roach or the right
missing the [ __ ] big picture right
what what is it that like you guys want
to do this that mainstream games price
hasn't done or tends not to do I mean I
think there's a lot of the conversation
about what people are scared to talk
about right and we don't have that
filter like I don't I don't I have
nothing that I'm like fine that's taboo
there's no taboo for me there's no taboo
for us I don't think that is a thing
that we can say that we won't talk about
in a kind of new Watson kind of
interesting way we want to have really
good conversations about all the things
that people don't want to talk about
right because we're all adults you can
have you can say a thing as long as
you're thoughtful about it then yes
totally fine and if you can defend your
position and it's awesome but if you
can't then you're screwed then you're
screwed but uh yeah yeah and I also
think that people that we have on like
they're kind of tired of talking about
the same things with medium over and
over and over again so like you can
still promote your brand in your game
you know without having to go through
the same kind of bullet point list of
like what it like is like if you promote
yourself as a great thoughtful person
people will be more inclined to check
out what you're doing you know and like
that's like really been like my
mentality behind every interview that we
go in is it is like you know like I'm
interested in everything that this
person does right right now not just
your sit in the person yes not just in
the in the brand or whatever in exactly
the game is kind of secondary when you
come on the show yeah I want to know
about you that's the reason why I'm
attracted to your game is because you do
something doh I mean you can Bobby
google everything about the game or the
most part we all kind of know where you
can go gamespot those place doesn't do
those things like it you can go those
place and go there and final they go but
trying to hear about why you do what you
do you're not gonna get that lets you go
to GDC or something like that most
people aren't gonna go little places
yeah yeah and we're gonna talk about you
to see a little bit more another second
I want to shift gears a little bit
though talk about mr. Matt Lee's here
hello my good friend yeah all the way
from the UK
you in about three years I know LSU just
have breakfast is great i'm on grayer
now get hair is still [ __ ]
magnificent still look like that got a
singer from the from the music i always
thought that with the aisle because it's
just got left its own a hard-ass band to
google in the world yeah it's true i
think i get the guy from Chromeo a lot
as well i'll get Dave ones i don't know
people just go is this you and I'm like
no I'm not a famous and talented
musician you you're a famous untalented
that's legally to be on the Jets and
what people may not you farm start up
shut up and sit down yeah bridged videos
on YouTube yes I guess the abridge
videos I thing that most people know the
most kind of did the playstation 4
abridged years ago and they kind of went
a bit nuts making went viral but then i
did a few more and i was like keep doing
more and it's like what i've done the
joke yeah okay so they're all marketing
presentations 10 more rubbish and after
you've done three of those it's like
there's nothing else that if you want to
see that joke again it still exists slow
but you can't anyway but i don't know
where to go you gave it for a while now
i do my own thing we do shut up and sit
down which is a board game website which
the aim of that really was to to kind of
explain to the world let the world know
that board games are awesome and they're
not like monopoly include oh and all
these dire boring things that you play
at Christmas with your family whilst you
wait to die they are like exciting and
vibrant and fun and none the coverage
out there was doing that was almost like
Wallace has a lot of pieces and a lot of
dice and it's just like we want
something which is going to be exciting
so we did that and then we started we
want a new challenge so we said to try
and make a website about video games
which had a really good community and to
see if we can actually make something so
every day you can go and look at the
comments and it's just like good stuff
and not just sick of fantic not just
like loads of people going oh we love
you people have conversations people are
being polite to each other and you know
we just sort of feel like that'd be
interesting challenge so doing that now
with cool ghosts which is a silly pink
website with ghosts on it yeah that's
like the second phase of your patreon
experience yeah on your own for oil as
well what was the impetus behind leaving
video gamer leaving like a job really
like solid wages you know somewhere to
work collaboratively with other people
to go on your own into the scary world
of patreon well I mean really it was
more to do with like wanting to do more
stuff with shall have to sit down
because
right that site was just kind of kicking
off it was exciting there wasn't really
many board game websites and there was a
lot of people who really loved it and
again like I thought you know I'd spoken
to Quinn and Smith who's like kind of my
partner in crime with a lot of stuff and
he really had this vision like wanting
to like make board games cool and wanted
to make them a thing and I thought I was
a really exciting thing because you know
it was it was kind of a mission worth
rallying bill yeah and I want to work
more with them and spend more time doing
them and I was basically I tried to work
it out so I could maybe go part time at
video game and like kind of split my
time 5050 we couldn't work it out and it
was actually I wasn't even intending to
Beverly video gamer it was just a case
of like I was kind of like all I want to
do this and I hope that they'd be like
okay I'm I played hardball and they just
went well no is open meeting right you
were you there's a mat anyway it was
really funny I just have this all could
be where I went well then I'm leaving
I'm kind of still expecting somebody to
give something and go well no let's not
but then we're like okay and that was
that oh yeah he's a block word hug man
awkward is like yeah things like you
know I had good relationship with all
those guys I still do and you know that
they're great people and there was no
hard feelings there which this case if
we couldn't make it work so yeah to be
honest I only started using Patrian
because I just sort of thought like you
know freelance is a pain and you know
you've got a special video at that point
that wasn't really a an infrastructure
for like pitching videos to sites for
being like I wanna make this video for
you it's kind of better now but back
then it was like you could only writing
so I figured that maybe if I could get
like a small handful of fans who like
what I do they could give me a tiny bit
of money and every month I could afford
to put a bit of my side all right to
make some videos but then it kind of
took off more than I was expecting I was
I guess I was quite early to Patrian yes
yeah and it was the reaction was really
surprising i was looking just like quite
small amount of money and it kind of I
got more than that and it was like oh I
can actually this can kind of be my job
mouth um was also scary because it's
like then you have to like yeah read
Joss to me like oh no this is actually
gonna take up more of my time oh yeah
like I almost really screwed myself
really early on that I mean it was kind
of lucky because wood shop and sit down
we actually like used our own
crowdfunding platform no it's very
similar to Patrian but we kind of had
our own tech and stuff so we'd already
kind of had some experience of like
doing that and I almost been a huge
mistake when I started doing the Patrian
of saying look if I get this much money
I make this many videos I forget this
much money I make this many videos and
my friend was just like well were you
doing like this is crazy like you don't
you know people don't want 15 videos
hyphen you don't want to be doing 15
videos a month like just yeah just don't
and it was this weird thing and I
thought about it a lot and i ended up
the sounds never sounds good when i say
i worked out that the best way to do it
was to offer people nothing and to
promise nothing which was bizarre
because i still have this conversation
if people say oh what are you doing I'm
like well I make videos about about
video games and they go I'll cool but
what's your job and I'm like what I do
that how do you how do you make money
i'm like well people just give me money
okay what what are you what do you get
the back and exchange for the money I'm
like nothing and then people are just
like looking me as if to go like it's
this guy's just a liar like it's just
lying to me um but I don't know it's
kind of it's kind of good to have that
that kind of honesty of that
relationship of just being like you know
people are giving us money because they
like what we make and they're not doing
it to get another thing and if they're
not happy with with just the quality of
the work enjoying it that's fine they
can tap at any point but I think if you
get into a habit of like offering more
and more what's up on them more like you
were once a Jew you have to make a 15
videos a week you know you're like yeah
and you don't make any good ones yeah
and right right i think not enjoying it
yeah i think there's a lot of tendency
like you know for that to be the thing
especially with YouTube and twitch
especially is a younger you know the
kids yeah coming up from behind and you
know that's and it's great but I kind of
also feel for a lot these kids because
they're really hustling but they're
doing it at the time when like when I
was a teenager when I was just playing
video games all the time and I'm
thinking like I'd be the same as them if
I did it start doing this when I was
like 17 18 but it's like it becomes
their lives and you know when you're a
teenager that's fine because you have
really got a life yet but when you're an
adult when you're like you know I'm 31
this week and it's it's like I'm not
ancient but I have a life and people say
are you going to do some streaming it's
like well I'm gonna spend some time with
my fiance I'm gonna cook dinner and
that's
room I think that work-life balance
becomes difficult and so it's kind of
been very slowly about us but trying to
find an audience of adults who actually
like weirdly right now if we make too
many videos they go I can't watch this
video yes it would rather have like a
few really nicely crafted things rather
than lots so look it's scary when you
hear 22 year olds talking about brand
management all right that's nuts how do
you guys bother with that then trying to
like find the time to do the work you do
yeah because podcasts are credibly time
intensive yeah yeah I think that they do
take a lot of time and I think that a
lot of people just think that it's like
talking on the phone like your time all
right bye and then this automatically
uploaded and like that's it but no
there's like a lot of meetings there's a
lot of like discussions about like Who
we're going to have on well you know you
know like what kind of articles are we
going to to discuss and I think that you
know for me personally you know I live
with my partner and you know we have to
I have to kind of let her know like hey
I'm recording on this night but it's not
just the recording because like that
there might be like a plus 30 or plus i
plus an hour at the beginning and the
end yeah you know to to a debrief and
you're fitting it around like a
lifestyle yeah like everything else you
do yeah so so because I'm an insane
database spreadsheet person I have like
you know calendar this is you know this
is where I'm gonna be at this is kind of
kind of what what what I'm doing and
things might have to shift around but I
at least have like that baseline so that
I'm not you know screwing over my
relationship you know yeah and you've
got as an utterly it's different you
can't just like drop everything you have
to be like oh yeah got some people
coming around by and I mean I i
basically coax people around to my house
to record podcasts by offering them like
dinner so like you know yours is like
you're as good smart abortion well you
ever London it Mia bus tickets pretty
expensive together I'm making me lasagna
honestly but ya know it tends to be like
you know that's that's because again
these people are adults and so it's like
you know will you come and give me your
evening and in exchange so it becomes a
whole night of being like they come
around you have some chat and you record
then afterwards you know you cook dinner
and it's like otherwise you know it's
kind of we don't have the budget to pay
people right but it's like I'll make it
worth their while like you know come
around have a nice evening yeah we got a
funny and you got a funny kind
it mike bithell was on the show and
we're like all right so especially the
time difference because i'm in i'm in
portland and my other co-host at the
time was still in chicago and it Mike
was like I was like what's that noise in
the back it's like my wife is making
dinner I rigueur feeling better like I
mean things clang in the back and I'm
like oh that's right you have to eat
like oh yeah but people don't really
kind of understand just how long it
takes to get things done in podcast oh
yeah yeah we did a Media Molecule
episode fairly recently and that's a que
year to get really that's a good Johnson
Parker I took a year to get just to get
through the process of meeting folks and
saying hello and then kind of you know
having those conversations over a year
to get a really good show to come over
that's why do you do that then when you
see like everyone else doing all these
like twitch streams and YouTube that's
where all this like crazy growth
happening right I know you guys do it
that stuff of those as well yeah like
your main focus used to be like this
like tough thing to do like having
thoughtful discussions on podcasts
especially when you don't have like like
there's a lot of like problems that you
guys have that because I've got the
gamespot name yeah they just disappear
in like trying to get people like that
one year yeah takes like a week right
it's like you guys have to hustle way
harder yeah so I what is it about why do
that honestly I think cuz no one is
doing what we're doing and I think that
that's it had a really good conversation
when we first started to do podcasting I
said you know it was a brand that was
like really well-known and asked them I
said oh I really love your stuff what do
we what do we need to do to get into the
game and I do it in a railway and he
said find your niche figure out what it
is you're actually going to talk about
and do that really really well and have
really good quality and we came out of
the box with really great sound and we
try to figure out what the actual voice
was for us and then we found it we like
stuck with that and that was with the
think and then we found out no one else
is doing what we're doing and that was
it so it was like knowing that I can
produce a really good show every week
yeah it's the best thing on the planet
for me and now somebody's about
listening uh we were just talking
earlier about like been doing this for
like I've been doing this professionally
for about four years even yeah it's
probably read similar right yeah I think
so yeah doc I feel like I've been like
consuming video and audio and text a bad
video game is like for like 20 years and
when I love this one on me is that it's
like oh it was fresh like this feels
like oh it's a different respect up and
then for her before which i don't think
i was expecting out of a podcast in 2016
it's interesting because we've been
growing up on pockets that we've loved
for years we had the one ups and giant
bombs and all those we love those folks
but they didn't necessarily have that
perspective that they can have these
conversations from and it was great to
see that you know when we decided that
we wanted to do it we said okay well how
can we do this in a way that no one is
kind of touching this and not be afraid
of it because we've had conversations
they were like oh so you're doing a
black podcast right yeah I guess we are
but we're not excluding people you can
definitely come into the fold we're not
saying you can't listen to our show
because you are not a person of color or
you're a marginalized first we want you
to listen to the show especially if you
aren't said you can hear these
conversations and like know what people
are thinking about and then you can
engage those conversations really
thoughtful ways this minute have been
happening it's been happening early yeah
and like as you see what sessions here
like the industry is attuned to these
issues ray of like diversity and I mean
it's it's getting more and rice yeah
this comes we have more conversation
three years ago we probably yes yes I
think there's a long way to go
absolutely but but like it I definitely
see some things turning um but you know
till I answer your original question in
terms of Y to do a podcast you know it's
really an extension of conversations
that we've already been having because
I'm known cuddly for years like before
we did the show and as he said I've been
listening to gaming podcast for a long
time and you know we just felt that we
had something new to offer and i just
love audio because i listened to most
podcast when i'm driving when i'm
running errands when I'm shopping you
know so I love video too but like I have
to be like sat down yeah you know at my
computer because I want to use my data
plan while I'm yeah well I'm going you
know so like I I think it's just a nice
pure you know way to get a new
perspective and also I so do a radio
show in like a my college so I just love
like just like haven't that like defined
kind of show yes weirdest like making
something that looks good like video
looks for guys is really satisfying but
actually just the richness of you get
really good audio babies think sound
lovely lovely that nuts so right that is
when you get like get to a really good
microphone freak listen it's
that's it's nuts we used to do a little
bit of you should be a little bit of
audio like little bit of music stuff in
there too and they see my favorite part
of the show yeah like drop a music break
in it oh and it sounds perfect when it
comes in did a fear game of the year
stuff yeah yeah we did like a little bit
of a call to soo was a radio Brokaw go
for a little bit and it was great I find
amazing there's so many like games
websites and so many game youtubers are
there's so much like so many people
creating like gaming content games media
content and yet so much miss huge
Suede's like all roughly just doing in
the same way doing the same stuff that
when you actually like want something I
mean I guess you guys probably end up
doing a podcast the same reason I end up
doing my stuff I'm like I don't actually
consume a lot of stuff because i'm not
interested in it right and I guess I
must have going well where's the stuff
that I would want to watch and then you
just end up making the thing that you
would want right yep right but then you
just want somebody else to do as well so
then you can enjoy and I'm still finding
myself being like well I make the kind
of video I make because I want it to
exist and it doesn't but now gets the
point where I'm like come on could
somebody else start there because I
quite like to just watch these now i'm
done with making over no i mean like
yeah that's why i like a love Superboy
hop so much because like the only reason
we started doing the point was that i
love Charlie broker young white yeah
like it was like watching him and he
used to be a gamester Nilis like years
ago yeah not like a writer and I was
like [ __ ] why doesn't he do like games
white every week it would be great yeah
like it's not tonight quality but like
that's what I was like that was that
dream was to do something bad and now
there seems to be quite a lot of it to
get like like I between like super bunny
hop and like you know totalbiscuit does
a bit of it and like a gym quiz Asian I
love lists watching their people like
actually like diving into that source ya
know there's that it's definitely
getting it broaden out which is cool but
I think there's still so many like
niches and I think it's funny how many
people come into it being like I want to
do it and then just copy like gamespot
or something okay and do be like here's
my preview of games that no one's really
[ __ ] pretty good no one all right you
just gotta know if I like what you can't
find and like you know it's it's funny
how like what for me that's changed over
the years you might it used to be like
wires they know like really funny stuff
through video game so I start doing that
and then it's like now it's like why is
anything that's just like about the
heart of video games why is there why is
it all like being critical and cynical
and being like well this doesn't quite
right as good as this game and it's not
what they promised us why isn't there
like stuff which is just like kind of
trying to express how video games make
you feel cuz the beauty of what you do
though is that you're super genuine when
you come across doing
doing your work and that's the thing
that people don't necessarily understand
yet oh yeah is like that genuineness it
doesn't really come through unless you
are actually trying to be genuine and
it's funny because people just think all
this guy's a bit of a shill sometimes I
some people say night because it's like
this guy's a shill every time he makes a
video about game he's like really
positive right right and it's like no
it's like I only make videos girls that
I think I would write write the
landscape we're working in it like there
is paid for content there's like website
you know like it's just happening like
big size like us as well my gen it HAP
does like paid for content that happens
there's like you know all the stuff we
saw with was a rooster teeth last year I
don't say something if I'm not exactly
right but like you know some companies
doing stuff under the table and then
like finding out like after the fact
like you don't do anything no it's a
weird kind of landscape and I is I mean
I remember how to really you guys don't
I'm sure they wouldn't mind so matter
under before funny train of emails we
can come about Dragon's Dogma because
way back when when I was oaks mi made a
video about Dragon's Dogma which went
viral it basically like it sold the game
right and then it went from being like
Capcom being like well we'll put it out
and it will die to being like oh we've
got a game to being like it was a minor
hit apparently I've been told by blue
working Capcom that like even in head
office they were like who is this guy
like did we do this like this to happen
oh it was just like it was just a
complete like chanting when I went to CD
Projekt they had like did you do
something about the witcher 3 yeah i
gave them more yeah he's saying the
least I think it was least likely to be
asked yeah and they had like a be framed
I don't know did the producer got a
t-shirt yeah oh yeah yeah then also cuz
it was like yeah I was a bit in the
producer being like [ __ ] you is the
witcher 3 and they got that premonition
yeah yeah and i get that great guys but
yeah capcom like when they were at least
a solid shell and they were leasing
Dragon's Dogma on pc they were like oh
like kind of like I guess cuz they knew
I'd done so much for the game originally
they kind of said to me like I'd you
wanna do some videos for and they were
like oh this is kind of awkward but like
you know is it how much it cost for you
to like take the time today I was like
oh no and I actually got upset because I
was like yeah they were like we want to
give you a preview copy the game so you
can make a video and I'm like yeah
wicked cool berry and then like yeah
let's talk money and I was like oh no
can you just give me the game right
right I never talk to me again who's
really
gonna get the game because I know now
that so much this stuff is advertorial
oh yeah I used to have this back on this
video game you know I know many
companies but I used to be like they'd
be like to make videos bats game I'm
like yeah that'd be awesome like when
can you sell me preview conan like well
how about you make 10 videos about the
different aspects where I'm like well no
like he just give him here and then they
just go um yeah well you'll get a review
copy and it was this thing of being oh
my god like that was kind of one of the
main things when i started going I've
got to get out of this system yes I only
got publishers you won't let you play
their game and make videos about it
unless unless you're taking money from
them right now it was crazy yeah but it
was really nice we kept calm be like can
I just do it because i like the game
without any money in that you don't want
money I fine yeah whatever they ever
yeah that is weird to be in this
situation you literally having to turn
down money and that's like it's weird
that this is that's not the norm anymore
right like that especially in video I
feel like that's not the case in Britain
but like it's because people are you
know everyone's like you know we work
really hard to kind of get into
positions were but we're kind of feeling
comfortable and doing well and but at
the same time like you know it's harder
and harder as less less jobs and right
people are trying to get in and I get a
lot of these kids they haven't had
business experience like you know I
advantage of working market research and
PR before so I kind of already been on
the dark side so because this thing of
being like if your media and then you're
selling out what's the point I should
have just said in PR right but a lot of
these kids they've got big audiences and
yet they not making any money and when
they're offered a way to make some money
it's like I get why they do it and I
don't look down it at all I think
actually the puzzle of trying to work
out how you can sustainably like make
something of something like that is
without like kind of compromising at all
is it's a really difficult puzzle and I
mean I think now let's like we're in a
stage where there's enough people doing
it that there are actually some
framework so you can actually work it
out but it's been a really weird couple
years like working now of being like one
of the few people who actually care
about that stuff and you trying to
actually work out a is this possible and
be how do you do it yeah you're right so
it shouldn't be as hard as it is to do
work for the sake of the work yes
exactly i mean the thing i found crazy
was like I had videos that were getting
like five six million views and they
were like earning some money but then I
had videos are getting 50,000 views on
you look at the back end of YouTube and
YouTube just goes nah
like six quid you're like yeah and it's
like especially when it's like we've got
10,000 people like I had this weird
think of like you know the mainstream
comedy stuff I did was getting big views
but then the kind of niche stuff I was
doing small views but still like 10,000
people coming back every week yeah and
it was like that I just realized like
are you saying you saying that 10,000
people worth nothing nothing and I just
hated that attitude so that's why I kind
of like the Patrian seem like a cool
idea and we're just so wrong with it but
it's weird our like I almost like my
always the thing I compare it to is like
did any of you guys have a magazine when
you were younger that you loved yeah
yeah and did that magazine go out of
print yeah yeah and and when that
magazine went out Brendan like would you
what would you've done to stop that from
happening money I subscribe an earlier
life isn't me we were already
subscribing a buying it yeah totally
yeah it wasn't enough twitch streaming
like the patreon muddle or the twitch
it's the same as buying a magazine yeah
and I figure it's like it's like buying
a magazine but instead of it being like
just you own it it's like you buy the
magazine and everyone can have it right
oh yeah yeah you are just ensuring that
that continues to exist because I still
get sad when I think about some of my
favorite magazines that stopped existing
yes I still have some yeah so it's kind
of weird but I think now the world is
kind of getting used to the idea of like
if people realize now that if you want
stuff to exist it isn't just this soft
modulus normal stuff rice paper by ads
then somebody's got to me that happen
basically and like it's not just gonna
happen like magic Senate and there's
that there's the whole like you know
audience side of it but it's also like
this whole like technology has leveled
the playing field as well whereas before
I mean like hosting a podcast isn't
cheap as well right like there's
actually you know what the funny thing
is the prices have come down a lot yeah
on that end a lot of people are scared
about the kind of initial buy-in there's
like I need equipment I need these dry
doesn't 3,000 other mics and like no you
don't yeah the first 50 shows that we do
on snowball mic like 50 bucks yeah and
then we moved up to like 100 buck mics
and then show sounds pretty good you
know sounds good now yeah and that takes
work too but it's like the initial
buy-in mmm but the ad space and Espen
that spot is even even more crazy like
they want you to have ridiculous amounts
of numbers right yeah into that game
talk this when you've got like over
200,000 or something I was like I'm not
dancing on anything I'm sorry you get I
don't have I don't have that many people
who like me to really get that get to
that spot yet but you know there's one
of those things but then
show by and the hosting stuff is there
it's gotten way cheaper than it was
before you go to multiple places you can
even kind of bargain sometimes and say
these folks are kind of doing it at a
cheaper rate maybe you can get in a bit
cheaper a fright yeah but it's all
initial buy-in its initial buying it
more time that is anything natural money
it's the cheapest game you can get into
if you want to like produce contacts
podcast now people i have they said to
me I want to do a podcast like and show
me this equipment they want to get and
say oh what do it it's like you know
actually you can have like the worst
script in the world and but if you're
doing a good podcast people will go high
sounds awful but it's great yeah where's
like a lot of people just go in with the
equipment actually don't think about
learning to podcast no secure saying you
did radium foreign it's like you know
doing that you just get better like I
think years of doing broadcast you can
just you will be a better podcast yes
yeah it's like more about finding your
voice yeah and I get the same thing with
blogging and like any kind of content
like a light creation but yes it is al
it is a great time technology-wise to
get into making videos or but like if I
you don't have that voice and like
you're not comfortable with like you
know knowing how to you know really get
what's in here out to people yeah then
your technology doesn't matter yeah does
my like I've heard plenty of great
sounding podcast but I deleted that a
few episodes get to the point man to the
point yeah absolutely you were talking
about like we're wanting to make
something that no one's made before like
I definitely think that that's that's
like a theme of what I've experienced as
well so for you guys like creating a
podcast you know you guys have been
consuming video game media for i'm
guessing years and years oh yes where
were all the African American Voices I
do they exist I just not do we not see
them like it seems so I do you mean like
specifically on the media so within the
media of games okay um I did not see
them when I was younger and I I remember
just like as simple things as you know
reading a copy of egm and seeing the
reviewer faces right scores I would
always kind of be like okay I really
like sushi X but yeah but yeah I mean I
it was weird because you know I grew up
in a majority african-american and like
Latino area and everybody played games
but we never saw right anybody in
the magazine oh it was like only
magazines at that time yeah but we never
really saw that but at the same time we
never thought of games is like a white
thing right because we all did it ya
know like we were Street Fighter 2
experts and we found all these secrets
and megaman and all this kind of stuff
so you know it wasn't really until kind
of later when you start to see people
you know like the faces of the people
that actually wrote these articles
that's when like for me I was kind of
like yeah me it really doesn't exist as
much as I want it and it's not because
you know obviously it's not because
people don't have the talent it's just
that there's like there's several
blockades to people getting involved in
an industry that number one you know
doesn't necessarily pay right a lot and
number two there's a lot of people that
are discouraged from going into certain
fields when they don't already see the
representation in the right a little bit
of the chicken or the egg thing yeah I
was like who is it and it was like only
person I remember seeing often was n guy
and I yeah alright yeah it was like n
guy we love doing guys like n guy crawl
and then later on you know it was kind
of writing and then behind the scenes in
front of camera which is the thing I'm
really kind of focusing on of like I
want to see more people in front of
camera and we're only seeing those folks
kind of like doing their own thing and
then kind of being kind of pulled back
in yeah so is like Malik Forte over at
Nerdist and stuff like that and then
like Austin Walker now a bomb and stuff
but it's like we were like there's none
of these folks there remember we kind of
talked about this earlier about another
reason why the pockets kind of started
it was a NeoGAF thread when they were
like are there any black journalists and
then yeah and people were like we were
like hey there's a bunch of people who
we can kind of point too but you don't
see see them tonight I'm not visible and
writers are like exactly yeah like you
can know that they're there as far as
like you can see their name on an
article but if you don't see them it
doesn't really connect in the same way
so yeah yeah put those people out there
and live yeah I'm not sure if I know
what Tariq Musa looks like yeah right
yeah right right right right besides a
cat with a pink back yeah
yeah and yet cuz I I do a video series
I'll sorry the podcast yeah called a
game looks good and I know that I've
gotten a lot of attention from that just
because people see my face right and
like they're like wow you're you know
you're a person talking about these like
issues in in in like games I don't think
everybody picks that up from the audio
and like that is I guess one purl two
like the videos that you're like hey
like I'm here and I know what I'm
talking about in like is that like a
double-edged sword because in one way
it's like oh it's great that like people
I you're like facilitating this audience
that clearly no one was was you know
that was unrepresented but in another
way does it feel like like why is this
happening in 2016 or like does it feel
like do you like tokenism does it feel
like you're basically like fitting a gap
which shouldn't need to hailed I don't
feel that at all cuz our quality is good
ya like like we have the content now if
we you know if like we were kind of like
hey like you know you should listen to
us because we're black but our content
didn't back it up that would be like an
issue but no I don't really feel it
isn't them [ __ ] up the white people
don't have that problem well they don't
have to justify the fact my wife never
America
yeah way outside a game you know I'm
done I'm you know I'm like a engineer by
trade so the same issues that i see in
corporate America non SF it's show it's
absolutely the same thing you know it's
it specifically was not only stem but
like I've seen it specifically in the
STEM fields but I talked to a lot of
like women in games over the past few
years and like having lots of like your
private conversations with colleagues
and stuff because now you know look you
don't want to have public conversations
about this stuff because it's yeah
whereas difficult but it's amazing how
like many female games right designer
who initially I whether they initially
did it or toyed with it of just actually
writing under ghost names i'm just
writing like with because they just
didn't want people to read their work
and under the guise of it being rude
allen because they found that like I
know a few people like a couple of
journalists who found themselves like
being really well-liked as writers until
the name change then certainly it's like
you know nothing and it's like what man
it's pretty horrible but i also think
we're starting to see I unfortunately
like um because now we have had a lot of
like career groups of like come of
people who've been doing this for like
20 years 30 years and always like
there's been some definite like real
negative obvious side effects of having
these like middle-class white bubbles of
geekdom being like that I've grown up
and now just like yeah so I think I
think actually like whatever I'm working
to just create slightly different things
for the next 15 years is like a really
good thing because it's like yeah you
kind of I think for a while I kind of
thought it was harmless I'm just being
like oh it's not too bad but now I see
increasingly it's like when you see how
virulent people are when when something
pops up that is not exactly what they
used to write um it's like yeah this is
a big problem it's like this sense of
ownership that's like you know like Oh
gaming has always been this like sort of
you know why middle class thing and it's
great now that we're letting the women
and the minorities in yes ski exactly
yeah where's like oh no you were there
the whole time right right right i mean
we talked about that often i was like
you know how do we how do we share what
we do in a way that's genuine to us and
we've had it for a bunch of times with
folks alike so you say that you guys you
know talk from this black perspective or
this person of color of respect i was
like yeah that's who i am as a person
that's young there are things that are
attached to me that come along with my
experiences yeah and i'm going to share
though
that prism and when we kind of market
ourselves and talk about ourselves to
folks and like do you guys say that you
guys talk about black stuff black stuff
I was like yes we talk about blacks have
we talked about all that stuff
fascinating I think one of the most
interesting things at the moment about
like the changing media and the way it
works is that you have people who like
everybody's like oh I don't like all the
big sites i don't like all the big kind
of eyes too he's too like brand and it's
to me yet but then when you have people
whose like hello I'm just a human people
just like why are they being
unprofessional right is weird thing
about what do you want like do you want
people to be honest and like not part of
a company but then when you're an
individual I people like I shouldn't be
saying that like might have people like
when I start talking about politics on
my feed I have people saying hey tone it
down man like we follow you so you hear
about video games you want to hear about
that buddy countries getting taken over
by [ __ ] like right now yeah shits
like get out I thought it's weird how
he's like you have people like almost
like policing you is it as a as you like
a Content machine and it's super weird
because it's like people have this
conversation about like we want this a
political version of this world that
doesn't exist like where do you live
yeah well what a political society live
somewhere where you can have fashion
you're [ __ ] lucky yeah yours though
you're like on a good spot right now
because everything is [ __ ] up so like
people saying like on everything just
stay as it is now it's like the most
political statement in the world you
know the scariest demon is I want my
country back oh oh god I was like at
where yeah which are which times like
you did not do I know the black people
can't time travel we can't go back in
time did you not know this there's a
physically little line but we cannot go
back where it's not cool and it's all
that stuff is so based on like just I
don't know like prejudices that exists
already because I should be in the same
position where I like I talk about Irish
it all the [ __ ] time yeah people of
irish it I can talks about st. Patrick's
Day I can talk about I mean I probably
after a while dipika take a look but
it's like just bring up something that
has to do with being a person of color
right and it's like oh you're you're
banging on that drum again words if I
say Guinness it's like oh it's cause
he's Irish you don't I mean yeah the
exact same thing yeah it's just like you
can't talk about who you actually are in
a way that makes me feel uncomfortable
yeah and then I have to ask you the
question of why do you feel
uncomfortable we should have a
discussion and a Guinness so there we
can have that nigga's allow me to make
a comfortable well we have a Guinness
hey it's been a long way you know a beer
summit oh my god that's you just think I
just I just I have a little tap here on
my part sorry I'm up you know I'm
nothing but racist it's my worst trait
but so how does it feel having done two
years as one on me then at this stage
does it feel like does it feel different
to what it did 24 months ago is it
harder or easier like yeah I mean I I
think in some ways it is harder because
you know obviously when you build up a
brand you know you're under more
pressure to deliver that every week but
because we love what we do and because
it's coming from a jail in place like
you know I look forward to that
challenge yeah like I like like I look
forward to our audience saying hey you
put out great content keep putting out
great Compton you know like we we we
kind of don't have maybe that lien see
that we had early on it like oh well
they're new you know and like me maybe
they'll screw up like a few times now
like we built up you know something
awesome so so so yeah I look forward to
that you know it's what keeps me going
and at the same time it just feels good
to really be making like an impact yeah
like I don't think we'd be on on
gamespot seriously screaming or or like
hobby and on IGN yeah why people are
paying attention and it just feels great
because you know what we're all fans of
like the industry and like it feels
great to you know be able to contribute
in this way and there's been good to be
even able to do like a couple of
different things at the same time so we
were doing some charity stuff on the
side too we doing that we did like a
black lives matter stream for for
charity we did a gosh abortion access
and ISS a stream that we did that was
like maybe a couple like MLK weekend
that's when we usually do it and doing
that stuff to like kind of bringing
those two things together has been super
fun and awesome because it's like we're
gonna do the hard thing the hard thing
feels good yeah it feels real nice to be
able to do in people like I really
appreciate the fact that you did that
I'm like that's what we're for that's
the job that we have like do that hard
thing and see if it goes I'm fostering
like a good community we're talking
about earlier right yeah you're in a
position now where you kind of decided
or maybe with within yourself how did
this thought process where I was lying
actually the amount of people who watch
my thing
is important it's more the quality of
like the discourse that's coming off of
what you're doing numbers are addictive
and once you had like a big hit of it
once it's very difficult to get her back
you get this incredible rush like I
still remember when the first thing i
did went mad and i found myself in a pub
just looking at my phone I just going
around to my girlfriend's friends and
saying do you know what red is like no
okay and I just eventually found it I
was like you already like you know
realise I'm I'm at the top of Reddit the
top me it's the top thing i'm still home
side leg I'm just that good but it was
amazing amazing week but then after that
you just find yourself being like oh
this video got a million that's all
right yeah yeah what's wrong with you
yeah so it was really hard to kind of we
my brain back off that and it actually
be like you know what actually my
benchmark has changed now like 10,000 is
great bike from 10,000 is perfect hmm
but is this weird thing of also
realizing that like you get so trained
to like especially working in media the
numbers numbers numbers but every
numbers a person and the thing I think
more about now is who are these people
only have 50,000 people setting up your
site it's like you've got 50,000 people
outside door well that's a good thing
depends on who those people are why
they're here and I think there's a
tendency in the games media to be
everything to just because it's such a
focus on hit people just go well yeah
we'll do all this cool stuff but then to
get the numbers will do stuff like you
know PlayStation vs xbox you know which
is better on this and that seems
harmless but the same time the nature of
that content is largely combative and is
largely about like feistiness and
fairness and that's fine but it means
the people you attract are going to be
people who are interested in fighting
right yeah and that's the problem with
all games website so really what we've
tried to do with our site now is to like
have a very small community where we
just have this like small group of
people we like it's a pretty profitable
site and we only get about 3,000 views a
day doesn't use as a day and that's like
still pretty good but like it's the sort
of thing if you tell it to people in
marketing they'll just go how are you
eating food but Pat you there like
that's weird yeah we do you yeah but
it's nice because it means that like we
do have this or like people coming in
but it's word of mouth and we actually
like try and avoid doing anything which
is going to get lots of people coming
because I think that the people you
attract um become your community and so
actually like just doing something like
every now and then but
well we'll just do this to get some
numbers it's like at what cost and the
problem is like often the people who are
combative and the people who are
negative become the loudest voices and
it means that that's why comments on the
internet are awful it's because the
sorts of people who have like
interesting nuance quiet things to say
they're not going to go near right
because it's already been dominated by
the wrong type of people right yeah but
I've I've always thought that you know
companies view that that's like the
risk-reward thing like their business
model says we want all these impressions
and we're willing to take a risk that
our community is gonna be somewhat
poisonous yeah I mean you go to like a
sales you know you try and sell
advertising they're not gonna say like
but are they nice people many of those
like 1 million people are like would you
have a cuppa tea right it doesn't matter
to those people but I thing is
increasingly what we're having like
sites like you know meet like my side
which is just run by like pretty much
just me know me um it's like who's got
to go and deal with these people who's
got to go through the comments as me and
it's like this weird thing and I think
it's at the biggest shame at the moment
with this current model is the fact that
in the recent years it's become this
thing now like oh you want to work in
games media like are you passionate can
you write can you make videos can you
podcast yeah are you a warrior would
really thick skin who can deal with like
people hating you and it's like why
that's it worse they're like how do we
get people with like nuanced ideas yeah
people who have like gentle interesting
who say the answer is you don't because
they're not fighters right and it's just
lucky that I can fight so it's like I
didn't get into this to fight the road
and you turn up and you're like okay I
have to do this right okay let's get
some gloves on my and it's like what so
I don't know like it's weird like
building a site from such a different
perspective of actually being like we
don't want lots of people to come and
I'm actually like weirdly afraid of the
day when suddenly we do something which
goes viral right which we will at some
point like I'm not being cocky it's just
knew we were at some point yeah um if
you throw a direct one it'll hit the
road and I'm worried about that because
it's like then like you gotta hope that
the community can like whether it and
stay the same and like maybe grow but
like not just be washed away yeah but
it's even simple things like you know
it's kind of done but our website is
bright pink like hot pink no yeah and I
like that and it works because the
amount of people he'll turn up that site
and go yeah video games I video games I
this website's hot pink oh you know I
got uh no filter yeah
when it turns out to us website goes I'm
not looking at websites pink it's like I
never want to see you again anyway just
you can leave it's like you're running
like a like a website like somebody runs
like a zombie survival compaq yeah we're
like just gotta hope that everyone who
comes in that door asking me questions
and I hurry people are you flying yeah
yeah and that you know that I'm reminds
me of what a cow was saying about hella
we say you know we we talk about black
issues on our pocket yeah there's always
be people saying oh you sure you want to
say that you might like you know maybe
dissuade people from listening we're
like yeah I have a problem with that
lens we do not want them listening yeah
the folks who do listen they know and
they're like okay so we know that you're
gonna talk about these things that'll
make me uncomfortable if you know I
don't know how to talk about to myself
and we're totally down for that yeah
yeah yeah I remember we had a very
specific conversation during our first
fundraiser where like we had some
individuals with the kind of gamergate
hashtag all right that were that were
like wow like i really want to support
this but you know but the show doesn't
seem like they really support our
efforts and we were like we don't and
way to our own and we don't really want
your support like I know this is a
fundraiser like we want a certain kind
of community yeah you know that that is
positive and that you know like
obviously we don't mind being challenged
and let's show that that disagree can
have a conversation about it but not
just anybody yeah we're getting stuff
wrong too and that's the thing we tell
people all the time was like we have a
very specific lens that we have lived
through and we're trying to figure out
what other people are going through to
and if we get it wrong please bro sorry
you know but and definitely check us on
it because that way you can get better
you know I've got to be honest live the
past like 5-10 years like it's one of
the weird things about doing so many
podcasts and stuff and doing so many
videos is like I kind of like you have
like a huge amount of your life is just
on record right right i have people
listening back and saying you know this
thing you were talking about years you
like a little bit sexist there well your
little bit transphobic and especially
with trans issues a lot of these things
have only come to light yeah the
mainstream very recent whereas that [ __ ]
but it's just the way it is right and
like increasingly i guess still get [ __ ]
all the time i get a message saying
you've maybe that wasn't cool and all
you can think is just go yeah yeah then
you've gotta live with a vibe yeah the
things you've said on record yes people
are going to keep
me and saying you said this and you have
to go yeah I'm sorry if I'm right right
now bro yeah it's about growth it's
about girls and that's the thing that
people don't get on the internet is like
you were a certain person at this one
time they had some really shitty tweets
back in when i first started even when I
was like I don't know how to do this
thing and then I was like I understand
that people are listening and I
understand that someone somewhere is
going to hear this or see this out of
context and I hope that like people who
are getting into this stuff now think
about the stuff from the start because
actually it's really hard to get back
like that the weird thing i found was
when i was doing these like kind of
funny snarky comedy videos and being
like taking the piss out of sony myself
i thought it was all in jest good jess
like he's gonna like tongue-in-cheek fun
fun but why i didn't realize was that
whilst i was getting all these new
followers new fans they thought it was
like mean yeah I liked it because it was
mean yeah and then you know what these
people were mean yeah and it's this
weird thing about now realize that my
big thing with community is I honestly
believe that like the type of content
you put out reflects the people you get
right so and I feel actually really
sorry for a lot of like big youtubers
because they're like you're some of them
are like doing really good work and the
good people but because that work is a
bit negative they just have to live a
life surrounded by negativity and it
just it's like it's really sad because
it's just like the thing you don't
understand is I'm think that marketing
guys in ad sales guys who just look at
the numbers and look at the money and
don't do is it you end up like even if
you have friends and even if you have a
good family around you like you spend so
much time like surrounded with the
community of your work that if you have
a community that like that doesn't like
reward you in terms of like makes you
feel good about what you do then that
just like absolutely just right like it
just destroys you yeah then you have to
apologize when you switch back to like
oh I'm nuanced and I understand that
this was a wrong thing that I did yeah
you have to apologize to your community
like oh I was evil and kind of mean for
like the first five years of my content
I'm switching now to a more kind of
chilled out person second I'm sorry yeah
like that's a weird thing and all cast
so with that I record a comedy podcast
called regular features they've been
doing it for five years now and it's
funny how like people discover it but
with podcast there's a tendency knots
people just go I like this channel i
watch it right they go back to the start
yes yes I find that interesting because
I was a different person yes yeah like
you know is this thing would be so many
people going ah ah hey what can you do
yes
done it I've if I get on a new show i'll
go back to like the answer some of the
time rated episode and you tear a
different man you know yeah yeah I hear
an Irish guy when I go back like this
like Heidi fiddly little kid on there
are five years I mean you've seen that
with like you know totalbiscuit doesn't
have comments on his videos right last
week PewDiePie had that you know
basically you know they pulled that bear
simulator game because Roy like he gave
it a bit of [ __ ] and you know that whole
troop of users just like crushed it you
know i mean there's a thing and actually
you know like I think told bisque
actually said it best many years ago I
sort of anything talking about it's like
being hit by tiny tiny hammers because I
still the best analogy ever actually is
like thousands of tiny hammers over and
over and over a none of them do anything
because they're tiny yeah then for
whatever reason just one comes in and if
anything with me as I felt moderation
was like vital and lovely don't get that
and I still get a lot people come and
say why don't you have comments on
YouTube and it's like well because I
think it's a part of my platform it's
like basically you're standing on my
land mounting right and so I feel like I
have to moderate it so I have to go
through and make sure there's nothing
sexist or racist no imma phobic in there
but then you know that's why I'm there
I'm not there to read them right aren't
really care but you need to go and find
these things and while you're there
you're just going past a list nasty
stuff and people saying personal things
about you and it's like you've gone out
like in like a radioactive suit out in
the wastelands you like do something
yeah and you're like it's fine
everything's fine I've got the suit on
I've got a su on but and after you've
been out there for like a day you
suddenly realizes a tiny hole and as
soon as you notice the tiny hole it's
too late you just you messed up and
honestly I think something will see in
like 10 years time we'll probably some
psychological research or something
which would just go oh like the human
brain is not equipped to deal with that
much input it's not about writing nice
things and things you're not supposed to
have a thousand people telling you what
they think of you in a day yes because
it just does something to your brain I'm
getting level guide yeah that just does
something weird to my brain it's not
good yeah and so how it's a hard thing
to kind of like pour yourself into
you're like wait a minute all these
people whoa that's weird it's weird
though because they'll be just one
comment and it'll be so bizarre and as
something that just somehow just cuts
right through you and opens the
floodgates utterly or does less person
boozing
in all of it I think I've still like
been thinking about it for a long time
but I remember one day where I was just
really bummed out about this comment and
I was like ice it was really harsh
really mean thing and I was like oh man
but then I would have time to say to
myself dude like you check this guy's
twitter-like right he's an actual nazi
like an actual like an action not just
like oh this guy seems a bit fashion
like an actual an actual not like no
shame swastikas white power light and
it's like when you find yourself being
like my brain is decided that I'm upset
because an actual not is it like you
think like brains are awful yeah but on
the flip side of that I'm sure you get a
lot of great great responses to do equal
that stuff i do but it's what's funny is
all it takes is the one there i dunno
why something through the human brain
but like you know the first time you get
all this like massive feedback it's like
a wash of serotonin is like swimming
dreamland yeah yeah Tom do you remember
what it was like when no one gave you
[ __ ] yeah yeah when you say something
and I was like nobody cares don't feel
like you made it but then then you just
ignore it and then from that point
onwards you get a thousand comments
saying you're great and you just for
whatever reason your brain just goes
this is not new information and it
treats every new like compliments as not
being new information but every negative
is like your brain does use it and when
you look at this it's interesting is
it's something wrong weird I think
that's always been a thing like my dad
does career stuff and he's always talked
about how people fixate on negativity
and you can have people going around all
day and saying you know I love your work
and I'm what are we doing and then
somebody else a your shoes are a bit
strange yeah and that's what you think
about four days shoes refresh semi fash
my white laces you have it because the
shoes white and laces are white why
don't know it is that over OTT thank you
to be your shoes that are really weird
my hands just think you think about that
for years you just wake up at night and
think remember that time that somebody
said that yeah we were lucky though on
that end we haven't really gotten a lot
of negative stuff towards us yeah we get
it when it's like big things happen and
we kind of put and interject ourselves
and so that stuff yeah like people
shouting from the outside in maybe kind
of serenity right like Archimedes dope
we were they're fine they're they're
good they check us when we need to get
checked and they they're they're good
when we need to be good but they we've
been lucky to have some really good
feedback from folks who we didn't expect
to get feet right from so we had like a
one letter I kind of have like put into
this one folder on my computer I always
look at when things are kind of crappy
and it was this older gentleman from
Germany he was like in his 50s and he
was like I never really thought about a
hip hop I never really thought about
what you guys are talking about as far
as like blackness hmm and thank you for
letting me understand about how awesome
de la soul is oh man and I was like my
job here is done yeah I have to show
ever I'm good I've done you've
introduced that I sell to yeah a cat in
territorial you know like yeah I think
what most of the negativity that like
I've seen is it really from within our
communities if someone takes what we did
and posts it somewhere else right like
like uh I got alerted to you know I did
this a video on on the recent call a
duty game because you know sort of the
racing dinner options at the givi were
really screwed up in the game and like
somebody took that and they posted it on
on reddit and I didn't know until
somebody said hey did you know that this
thread about your video has like you
know 25 negative comments right I think
well I shouldn't look should i but then
you do yeah yeah yeah so so we we've
been lucky that like we haven't had it
like you know like people emailing us or
our twitter account getting flooded
would we ever made it to stormfront yet
i'm waiting at the store from him like
we're doing our job but i love that
about that way came up with the division
right like you guys were saying like oh
you immediately got like that like a
white dude right when you went at first
and then the like community was like oh
no actually like I got an Asian lady or
I got like yeah but like if you weren't
it's kind of messed up the like there
are certain people who have to be the
vanguards for that change right for that
change to come in and be normal
change is starting to become normal but
you need someone to run out into the
front line I get punched in the face a
couple of times before that change
happens right I mean I think it's double
though because I mean yes absolutely
right on that and I think you have to
kind of give people kudos when they
actually do some do some of it right
because I think that only informs them
to you know people get the negative
feedback of like why did I get this one
thing and then you're like oh wait a
minute the the woman who is a doctor
she's in a lesbian relationship right
give you kudos for that like you did
that and it was super just put on the
table and it was easy no one had to
think about it yeah it wasn't something
I was like made into this huge thing
yeah like arrows pointing at it was like
she has a girl version wife like no it
was like she has a wife and then you
just keep moving and I was great like
those things balance themselves out in
some ways you have to kind of
acknowledge that stuff to you to make it
even yeah and and that ties into what
you were saying mad about how negative
think and ken likes it sometimes you
know take over the conversation when
there's all these pieces of like
positivity I think that you know some
companies and media spaces are scared to
touch it because like they're they think
that this one thing that they might get
wrong because they don't really
understand you know the entire concept
will screw up everything missile such as
they've made they've made their bed and
I think it I think is that's one of the
main reasons that like I don't think I
could ever go and work for a big media
company ever again is because so many of
the big games media companies and it's
not like their fault it's just that
people didn't understand what the effect
would be when they did it but now all
you have these huge communities and it's
just like a nest you can't get rid of it
it's just there and now Peter you have
sites where people like a comfortable to
just like start a flaming thing about
which is better this week the x box will
appear sport but when I sinus you like
this they kind of go and it's just if
this difficult thing of like yeah Abby
it seems like that when you have
something like this like oh yeah this
just a game like shipping this snob big
deal like it seems like that wouldn't be
a big deal but then it still is a big
deal in these communities and it's
because you kind of realize that
actually that the most vocal parts of
what we think of like has been gamers on
game sites right are a tiny part yes by
huge beaver by minority it makes it look
like this is a problem when it's like
most people don't give a [ __ ] yoshiebutt
I'll give a [ __ ] but it's like most
people don't go [ __ ] and you still have
to hire more people like get those
people on the team so you can have those
conversations and not be afraid of it
it's the only way it moved
yeah that'll be natural yeah because
then people just talk about it folks I'd
love to keep talking to you we got to
wrap this up we've all got more crazy
GDC subject to get up to before we leave
though as where can everyone find your
guys work you guys have a patreon as
well we do have a feature on you can go
to patreon.com/scishow on me to help us
out because we need some money for the
lights you know you can check us out on
NPR one NPR earbud itunes and a couple
other spots on spawn on dat me is where
we have our site so you can check us out
all those place with sweet and sri
fraser youtube channel yep so my it's a
gaming looks good calm that's where all
my videos on diversity and gaming are
and obviously all the spawn on me stuff
that cost share as well oh yeah yes and
that FM that's our home that's our
solution we read you're awesome and Matt
what are you up to well yeah you like
board games you can go to shut up and
sit down calm it's pretty silly but ball
games are awesome if you just like video
games and you're not averse to a pink
website from the full of very friendly
people then you gotta call ghost on that
and check out some of our stuff on there
if you want something a lil bit
different smashing I love it thank you
so much any bottom Sharif Jackson Matt
least thank you all so much for coming
on and thanks to everyone for listening
or watching these special GDC sessions
this week if you missed it we had
marchini vince key from said their
project ahead which i think i pronounced
right now whoa thanks very much
yesterday also had the saltzman's and
mr. Jim Crawford of frog fractions fame
on yesterday as well so if you're on the
podcast feed those are already on the
feed you go back and download them if
you're watching this on video at youtube
parking spot thank you so much to
Marrakech and Eric day for putting all
these together and thanks to you guys
for listening or watching s you next
week when is no GDC bye
you